Can Smoking tobacco and Drinking beer actually
be … good for you?
Hey Everyone, Crystal here for DNews.
I think your mother and your doctor would
both agree that smoking and drinking are not
healthy habits.
Something about lung cancer and cirrhosis
of the liver, I dunno … but both tobacco
and hops have a healthy little secret.
They contain a high concentration of compounds
that may help protect your brain cells against
neurodegenerative disease.
Both Parkinson’s and Alzheimer's Disease
are major health concerns in the US.
These diseases are characterized by degeneration
of neurons in the brain.
and no small neurodegeneration mind you, at
the point that Parkinson’s Disease is usually
diagnosed over 50% of the dopaminergic neurons
in the brain’s substantia nigra region are
already gone.
Research is currently being done to understand
how we can best interfere with the progression
of these diseases, and many a pharmaceutical
company is hoping to develop drugs that don’t
just treat the symptoms but that can actually
protect our brains from cell death.
Ironically, some of the most promising compounds
being discovered are found in some pretty
unhealthy places.
Smoking continues to be a leading cause of
preventable death worldwide, but nicotine,
the addictive component found in tobacco smoke
may have neuroprotective properties!
And trials are being performed to investigate
the inverse correlation between smoking and
Parkinson’s Disease.
Weird right?
If you’ve ever smoked a conventional cigarette,
you’ve lowered your risk for developing
Parkinson’s.
A recent article published in the Journal
of Agricultural and Food Chemistry identified
another compound found in beer, Xanthohumol,
as being potentially neuroprotective.
When scientists challenged neuron-like cells
grown in a dish with destructive oxidizers
like peroxide, over 60% of the cells died.
But when the cells were pre-treated with xanthohumol,
they showed 25% more viability than the cells
not pre-treated.
The researchers were also able to demonstrate
that this was due to an increase in the cell’s
ability to defend itself against stress, and
not due to direct interactions between xanthohumol
and the oxidizing agent.
Xanthohumol is emerging as something of a
cureall antioxidant and it has already attracted
attention due to its role in cardiovascular
protection, as well as its anticancer, antiviral,
anti obesity, and anti-inflammation properties.
And right now, high (micromolar) concentrations
of the compound has only been found in beer.
So hoppy beers and nicotine might be good
for your brain, but be careful to stay on
the lower end of exposure.
Cancer, heart and liver disease are a poor
exchange for Parkinson’s and Alzheimer's.
And because I know some of you are going to
ask: no, the two won’t cancel each other
out!
No amount of “anti-cancer” and “cardiovascular
protection” beer drinking will prevent the
development of heart disease and lung cancer
if you smoke like a chimney.
What do you think?
Is your lifestyle helping or hurting your
brain?